[Music]
welcome dear friends to this program I'd
like to know it is always a blessing and
a privilege for us to interact with you
and we thank you for sending your
questions your uh inquiries to our
address which is tvam tv.org we are
delighted to hear from you and we always
make the promise to you that we will
answer the questions as we receive them
there's a lot of them so you have to
have a little patience but we do our
best in getting them and we will answer
them again as we have receiv received
them and so today we have I have Pastor
Daniel Miranda with me Pastor what a
blessing to have you once again thank
you for being in this program thank you
I'm enjoying the questions very much so
I'm looking forward to it amen and we
have some good questions and we look
forward to them now before we open God's
word and we answer the questions Pastor
can you please lead us into prayer as we
need to have the Holy Spirit to lead us
into truth yes let's pray Heavenly
Father which are in heaven as we again
get ready to answer these questions we
do not trust on our own wisdom we trust
in the wisdom that only comes from you
we pray that as we open the word of God
you may guide our minds to the right
answers we pray all these things in the
name of Jesus amen amen am amen pastor
we have a question actually several
questions from a friend from Kenya his
name is Martin and he wants to know he
wants us to help him understand the
following subject the following
questions so the first thing he says is
this being an Adventist I believe in
death and resurrection of Jesus but I
also understand that he was fully man
and fully God now my question is did did
the divine nature of Jesus
die and if so is God also subject to
death so let us go first to this
question because since we have several
other questions by your friend Martin is
better we actually answer one at a time
so uh what can we say pastor about this
did Jesus
die uh did his nature die when he died
his a divine nature well uh the answer
is no because the Bible is clear that
God is Eternal if it is if he is eternal
there is no way for him to experience
death he doesn't have a beginning he
doesn't have an end he is the I am the I
am and if he's the I am Jesus several
times introduced himself in John 10 for
example as the I am in John 8 as well
that means the self-existing one the one
that exist throughout eternity so there
is no way for God to experience death
and Jesus when he died only he's human
Human Side that now you asked me to
explain that how how that was well I
cannot explain it is a mystery how those
two natures combin and at the same time
only one died the Bible says the
Incarnation of Jesus is a mystery is a
mystery in in 1 Timothy uh
3:16 uh but but we also have some
biblical evidence uh for that I believe
one of them is here in John Chapter
2 um
John chapter 2:
19 and and uh through 21 and if you
Pastor would like to read that
yes John Chapter 2 right verse 19- 21 it
says
here Jesus answered and said unto them
destroy this Temple and in three days I
will raise it up then said the Jews 4
and six years was this temple in
building and will thou ra up in three
days but he speak of the Temple of his
body okay so Jesus is saying here that
he himself has the
capacity destroy this Temple his body in
three and the third day I will raise it
up yes he was referring to his so if he
himself had the ability to raise up that
Temple is because he didn't die amen his
Divine part go also in John 10 177 and
18 I was actually going to go there it
says here therefore that my father love
me because I lay down my life and that I
might take it again no man taketh it
from me but I lay it down of myself I
have power to lay it down and have power
to take it again this commandment have I
received of my father okay so again he
he has the ability to lay down his life
he has the ability to take it again um
now some people might say well but it
was the father who resurrected Jesus
well in in John in in Romans 8 uh verse
11 it says that the Holy Spirit also
resurrected Jesus but here we read that
Jesus himself
resurrected how do we explain that well
actually the godhead the three members
of the godhead the Trinity was involved
in the resurrection of Jesus the father
gave the Commandment as we just read
here right um through the Holy Spirit
came who sent the
angel and Jesus when he received the
order the Commandment from the father
then he was given the permission to use
his divinity to resurrect again so this
is the way it worked and it's important
to to point out that Christ had to taste
death for all of us yes he had to
actually experience the penalty of sin
to atone for sin and um so it's not that
Christ had a show some people you know
uh you know when they think about this
that oh Jesus didn't really die then you
know Jesus was not an actor not a
Hollywood you know production he
actually had to to have power over sin
he had over death itself he had to beat
Death by dying so this is why he can
give us now the Assurance because he
conquered that which was unknown to God
right which was death itself but he
conquered through the ability of
becoming one with us a man and again as
you mentioned the fullness of this
understanding is not for us to be able
to comprehend it goes beyond our human
understanding how God fully became a man
and they were both fully God and fully
man at same time but all that we have to
take as as the Bible says is that Christ
died for our sins he died he tasted
death he tasted the second death for us
really and in that experience he had
victory death over sin yes amen all
right so let's go to the second question
Pastor now the second question is this
we had a very hot discussion one Sabbath
afternoon last year about the aftermath
of the infants who died before attaining
the age of knowledge of good and bad
some said that there is no hope for them
but I was of the idea that their
judgment would be based on the Deeds of
the parents especially with reference to
the time of Noah and destruction of
Sodom and Gomorrah please clarify so he
has this question that I've seen this
kind of questions debates and arguments
uh from time to time within our uh
Church Brethren and so I I I appreciate
the fact that they're studying but I
think that need to be uh careful not to
get into a heated argument where they
don't maintain the unity among the
fellowship so um what can we say pastor
about this then you know why is it
important for us to or what can we say
about this question that some people may
really have you know uh struggled to to
to to see or understand what does the
Bible say so if we go to the Book of
Jeremiah we have a interesting prophecy
there um Jeremiah chapter 31 and verse
15 MH Jeremiah
31:15 a number there I can read it for
you yes please thus said the Lord a
voice was heard in Rama lamentation and
bitter weeping Rael weeping for her
children refused to be comforted for her
children because they were
not now um verse 16 16 thus said the
Lord refrain thy voice from weeping and
thy eyes from tears for thy Work shall
be rewarded said the Lord and they shall
come again from the land of the enemy so
notice that notice that promise so
Rachel is is here weeping for her
children this is actually in reference
of the uh captivity when when actually
the King was taken captive right there
when Rachel had died when she was given
birth to Benjamin um so the prophet is
making an illusion to that and he's U
pointing here actually toward the
prophecy when Jesus you know was a baby
uh was a baby and this whole Slaughter
of little children and and Jesus was
spared but all these little children
died the question is what is going to
happen with them what the Bible is
telling us here what is going to happen
with them it says that they will come
back from the land of the enemy so these
children are going to be saved now of
course this doesn't settle the issue
because
um like what's going to happen with the
children of unbelieving parents for
example we have another example in the
Bible in in Exodus chapter 11 and
chapter 12 the the 10th plake the death
of the firstborn mhm we we see there
that only the children the the firstborn
I believe there were some firstborn
children that were babies okay of course
new couples that had their first baby
male um you know if they had not applied
the blood on the doorposts the angel
would have come and destroyed them but
it was because of the faith of the
parents that these children were were
safe were spare exactly and I have a
quote actually here from Ellen White
this is um selected messages volume
three page
34 it says I know that some question
whether the little children of even
believing parents should be saved
because they have had no test of
character and all must be tested and
their characters determined by trial the
question is asked how can little
children have this test and trial I
answered that the faith of the believing
parents covers the children as when God
sent his judgments upon the firstborn of
the Egyptians interesting yeah then she
says the word of God came to the
Israelites well she's going to describe
the whole thing here but let me go a few
more
paragraphs
um here same page actually next page
314 God sent a word of comfort to the
ber mothers of Bethlehem that the
Weeping
Rachels should see their children coming
from the land of the enemy Christ took
little children in his arms and blessed
them and rebuked the disciples who would
send their mother away saying suffer the
little children and forbid them not for
unto such is the kingdom of heaven now
how about the children of unbelieving
parents it says here
some uh some parents allow Satan to
control their children and their
children are not restrained but are
allowed to have Wicked tempers to be
passionate selfish and disobedient
should they
die should they die these children would
not not be taken to heaven the parents
course of action is determining the
future welfare of their children if they
allow them to be disobedient and
passionate they following Satan to take
them in church and work through them as
shall please his satanic majesty and
then I don't want to read the whole
thing this is very amazing but then she
says but it is also true that some of
the children of unbelieving parents are
more obedient that the children of
believing parents so that's why
believing and unbelieving does not all
settle the the matter because uh it is
not of believing children only by
profession It Is by practicing parents
whose correct whose whose uh you know
children are saved are covered by their
faithfulness it's not only because the
parent goes to church is because they're
faithful parents which at the same time
some parents who are not of the faith
but are righteous people you know in the
you know the the the norms of society
they do things well and and actually
their children give better testimony
than the children of some parents in the
church Len y says this matter hasn't
been settled to me and we better live it
where it is yeah and I think it's
important Pastor that you you mentioned
this about you know the children of the
unbelievers versus the children of the
unbelievers it you know it's something
that we don't have a 100% well the Lord
has not revealed to us hasn't revealed
it to us completely and but we know
their principles and that is is as you
have mentioned the it seems that those
who have children and the parents while
they're still babies while still infants
the parents are faithful to the Lord and
something happens to them they die to
the sickness or disease the Lord
promises those parents that they will
receive their babies again that God will
give them infants I know many uh
examples in my own experience with
people in the church who have lost
babies you know in in child labor or
well still in the womb or really early
in their ages and you know often I think
that those parents who have experienced
that pain of you know losing a baby a
child they can look forward to the
opportunity to raise their children in
heaven if they're faithful so I think
that the principle that that the
child um a baby until it's of age to
know between good and evil between you
know to make decisions it's subject to
the
parents spirituality the parents
experience I think is a a kind of one of
the the the clear indications that we
have uh now what happens if that child
or rather that parent while the babies
you know while they still have the
children and they still are you know
with them and they die the parent was
faithful but what happens years later
what happens the parent disappears or
moves away well you know it could be
that the baby's still safe because at
the time when he died the parent was
faithful and this sort of to me gives a
little bit of an indication an
explanation why there will be babies
without parents in heaven Spirit
mentions that actually in second um
select messages page 260 she sees
infants who have no parents yes so it
can't be the case that while the parents
is faithful that child is sealed for
eternity yes but that doesn't guarantee
the parent from trans changing the
future or going against the Lord so
these are things that again we are not
making 100% of absolute declaration
because there's no light specifically on
this subject but I think that our Duty
right now is if I have kids I need to be
faithful to the Lord if they are linked
to my salvation while they're still
babies I gotta do what I you know I got
to do my right part I got to be the
parent that shows the Lord and the love
of God to them so that they can be you
know saved in the cas of of them dying
early on you know and I think that's
kind of the main thing about that amen
all right so let's go to the third
question he has some people here in
Africa believe and this is a very
interesting
question uh and it might you know be a
little bit uh sensitive sensitive yes to
to discuss to some people uh but it says
but this is important some people here
in Africa believe that Christianity is a
white men's tool to keep African poor
this they say with ref reference to Old
colonization where our forefathers were
mistreated by the so-called Christians
where they took our resources living
Africans
impoverished in other in the other words
can we trust Christianity so this is an
argument that I'm assuming and and and
you know it's is used in Africa right
for declaring that Christianity is a wi
men's religion as they oppressed as they
abuse of their power as abuse of the
resources but how can we answer this so
you know so that we are are you know
they can be trusty of of they can trust
the Christianity right well
unfortunately many Christians did this
this is true many Christians did this
there were colonizers in Africa and the
early beginnings of this nation I mean
some of them were doing the same thing
here in America of course uh during the
time of colonization of uh 13 colonies
so it is a unfortunate that this kind of
testimony has been given in in history
by Christians and and I I can understand
I can understand these people why they
say that now the question is in other
words can we trust Christianity and my
answer to that is that you can trust
biblical Christianity you cannot trust
men that's a simple as that because
though certain people have
misrepresented Christianity doesn't mean
that I should not trust the Christian
principles that we find in the word of
God and I have a I have um a text that I
want to share in Romans chapter
3 uh here Paul is arguing about the
unfaithfulness of the Jews and this is
what he says um Romans
chapter
3 uh let's
[Music]
begin with verse one
through verse 4 what advantage then has
the Jew the reason why he asked this
question is because in the previous
verses he's saying that actually
circumcision or like is nothing is the
circumcision of the heart and he was
rebuking the Jews for some of their sins
so the question is then what advantage
then has the Jew or what is the profit
of
circumcision much in every way chiefly
because to them were committed the
Oracles of God for what if some did not
believe that is some of the Jews did not
believe will their unbelief make the
faithfulness of God without effect and
notice the answer yeah certainly not
indeed let God be true but every man a
liar so I could transform this question
where it says will their unbelief that
is the Jews unbelief make the
faithfulness of God without effect so I
can say will the wrong testimon of
Christians make God's faithfulness
without effect certainly not no
certainly not so yes these Christians
some of these Christians they used
Christianity to oppress and and slave
some of the
Africans but that doesn't mean that this
destroys the faithfulness of God and the
truthfulness of scripture ien pastor and
and you know also I think that it's it's
sad that um the heritage of Christianity
in Africa uh is linked to just the white
colonization I think that um if we
actually look at the Bible in the
scriptures in Acts chapter 8 we know the
story of the of the Ethiopian offical
official uh that came to worship God and
who was baptized by Phillip and he took
the gospel the Ethiopian took the gospel
to Africa and was the first evangelist
you of that beautiful continent now I
know that God had faithful Christians
throughout the centuries in Africa amen
it was not white men who brought the
religion and this is something that you
know I think that is important to you
know for for for our friends in Africa
to understand that God you know does not
make any exception of persons that
Christian Christianity is not a a
thankful is not a uh you know a a race
based religion is a religion based in
the love of God in Christ who came as a
man to die for us and so I think that
you know when we hear these arguments we
have to remind remember our friends that
Christianity is before you know the
conquest of the of the white you know uh
colonization I think that they need to
go back to the word of God and realize
that God had already established his
presence his gospel in Africa and and
yes as you mentioned even though there
is bad examples and and in name of
Christianity there has been atrocities
made specifically by several groups and
churches God himself has had his
faithful people yeah and when he calls
us to the light we're not you know we're
not drawn to a a a church that is made
by a culture or by a you know U GE
geographical location or by a particular
race we are called to be part of a
worldwide movement yes that Embraces
every single human being who is being
made to the image of God amen amen so
let's lastly he has one last question
Martin is a studying a student of the
Bible so we thank you for that and we
let's see if we can answer this in in
the last couple of minutes we have it
says if God looks at the motives behind
every action why did
usza in 1 Chronicles 139 And1 uh why
usza after laying his hands on the Ark
of Covenant and it seemed as he was was
just wanted to save it from hitting the
ground what he died I mean why was the
Lord so harsh on you usza to destroy or
kill him when he was trying to do the
right thing and so is he saying if does
God look at the motives behind every
reaction well actually there is more
that just simply trying to save the ark
from hitting the ground uh usza was a
katte he was he was a levite he was
supposed to know uh
better what uh what the Lord had had um
established in regards to the
transportation of the Sacred yeah uh you
know vessels and Furniture of the Lord
in 2 Samuel 66 the same incident and
seven it says a little gives a little
bit more details it says when they came
to naon stretching floor usza put out
his hand to the Ark of God and took hold
of it for the oxen stumbled then the
anger of the Lord was aroused against
and God struck him there for the error
for his error and he died there by the
Ark of God and and um so it says that
what was Us's error number one he did
not prepare himself as he should before
he was supposed to touch the the vessels
that there was a whole ceremony to have
to go through the cleansing and all that
which reflected also the the cleansing
the spiritual cleansing of the heart
number two he was never supposed to
transport it in in animals in Oxen uh he
was supposed to transport it on his
shoulders the the coites number number
three is that he was not supposed to
touch it okay or hold on hold hold on to
it and and uncover it so so this was his
error and and God demonstrates by this
that we cannot play with sacred things
we we need to take sacred things very
seriously and this is how God how
serious God is about that amen I think
this is important as you mentioned to
keep in mind that sacred things require
us to you know to to raise to the level
of God and not to bring him down to our
level so I pray that this question may
answer Our Friend Martin and I pray that
you will also be blessed we thank you
for your time and we look forward to
spending more time together here and i'
like to know may God bless you
[Music]